i've been asked
to make
content about why
the pursuit of what we typically put
in this north star position of
desire especially when it is
external
these worldly pleasures
why that is empty
and therefore the
title of the video being the indirect
path is a parody
on what is the direct path in the
spiritual traditions which is when you
turn
inwards most efficiently
to uncover the kingdom of god within
and to realize the infinite oneness
that everything is and so the
indirect path is when you don't turn
inward
the indirect path is when you
hold on to your
identity of separation
when you hold on to all of the
constructs
that you've built
subconsciously about
what you need to obtain in order to be
whole in order to be validated in order
to be
seen in order to be
happy and peaceful
and so the most common ones
that are pursued are these
so the first one is shopping or
consumerism
there's a whole branch around
retail therapy that is being studied
where people think that based on
purchasing material items
that they are going to feel better they
are going to heal their depression
they're going to heal
their anger they're going to heal their
anxiety
they're going to heal their sadness
but the exact opposite is true
you get a little hit of dopamine when
you get something new
and then you realize how empty it is if
you practice
realizing how empty a new materialistic
possession is
then you will soon very clearly figure
out that everything is based in
consciousness everything's based in
awareness everything is based here
fundamentally and not
in the object itself
you get a new pair of headphones let's
say it's a really nice pair of bose
headphones that are 300
and then what happens is is that you
realize right away
rather than
months down the line when the pair of
bose headphones falls onto the ground
or you lose them or whatnot that you
realize
right away that the bose headphones are
there just to serve your consciousness
they're they're just to serve your
awareness they're there just
for you to more
optimally execute your goals just like
this computer is
there's no materialistic
connection anymore to the computer
there's no consumeristic connection
anymore to the computer
the computer itself these cameras
themselves are meant
just to actualize the goal for example
the rolex or the yacht or the sports car
or the house in the suburbs or any
materialistic consumeristic possession
is almost always used
as something to attain happiness or
attain
peace or attain validation or worthiness
or fulfillment
but instead i'm asking you to shift your
lens where instead of
buying the nice pair of headphones in
order for you to
feel happy instead of buying the
computer for you to
feel happy what you're doing is you're
buying the possession like a computer
to optimize your north star
to optimize you executing your biggest
goals
and that's a big shift from i'm gonna
get the sports car in order for me to
get
a romantic relationship in order for me
to attract
friends that see how rich i am
completely different perspective shift
and you have to do that with this first
one around shopping and consumerism and
materialism
in order for you to see how empty it all
is it's empty
it's empty the new dress the new suit
the new watch
the new car the new house the new
stocks in your portfolio the new
even simple things like this is a pair
of headphones
that is not bose and it's a sixth of the
price of the bose ones
but they do an incredible job and i've
had them for several years
and so just to say that there's no need
to go
and buy the bose ones do you see the
difference
when you've had a phone for two years
and it still works well there's no real
need to go and get the next one just
wait until that phone or that computer
no longer can technologically do what
it's supposed to do
or you need a greater chip in order to
process the software that you're running
for
3d animation or whatever you're doing
and then get the next piece of
technology
so you see i've had this camera
equipment for almost
four years now i don't need to make an
upgrade in the equipment it still does
its job
fantastically so you see this is the
difference
you're using the technology you're using
the equipment to actualize a north star
you're not using the technology or the
equipment
to be like hey guys look at me i have
the newest version of this computer
look at me you should be friends with me
based on how wealthy i am based on how
much stuff i
own you see
so this is the shift with the first one
shift it to helping you actualize your
north stars
rather than trying to extract peace and
happiness through shopping consumerism
and materialism
and that's already a massive shift
inward towards the direct
path everything's based in your
consciousness and your awareness
it's up to you to shift your perspective
perpetually to
peace and joy using the breath
to tap more into that oneness
and less into that separation
the second one's also really common it's
also known as the relationship
fallacy um if you watch that episode on
amir talks on bentino masaro's channel
it's a really good one
we think that we can obtain peace
and happiness and joy by a partner
you can't you can't people want to
own another person you can't
you can't fill a void in yourself with
another person
you can't you'll learn that the hard way
it's the indirect
path you don't want to try and get
happiness and peace from a boyfriend or
from a girlfriend or from a husband or
from a wife or from a family or from
kids
you're not going to get fulfilled that
way the only way to get fulfilled
is to turn inward and feel the
already always wholeness of the
god-realized state
where you become the sun that
perpetually
unconditionally lovingly is always full
and shining
so all of the indirect path things can
be viewed as clouds
so you're clouded by thinking that your
cup is only half full and the way to
fill the other half of your cup is by
getting a boyfriend or a girlfriend
it's not it would actually
be most useful to you most likely
to spend significantly less time
or even completely deleting in fact
the hook up culture applications from
your
smartphone spend
way less time in shopping malls
you see for several years i've been
wondering
if time spent in shopping malls is
correlated
with lower actualization
and i would say that that's fairly true
the more time you spend in shopping
malls the less actualized you are
and the same thing's true with spending
more time on
hookup culture applications the less
actualized you are
so by
spending less time shopping malls by
spending less time
on trying to seek a boyfriend or a
girlfriend or a husband or a wife or a
family or kids in order
to fulfill you what you will do is
you'll inherently
make the turn inward rather than trying
to seek things externally
and you're going to become more
interested in consciousness more
interested in awareness more interested
in this kingdom of god within
in unlocking this infinite oneness and
when you do that process you recognize
more and more that
all these [ __ ] subconscious beliefs
that you've picked up
throughout your life that are focused
around unworthiness or needing to get
validation or peace and joy from
externally
all that [ __ ] dissolves and when
that [ __ ] dissolves it is so
freeing because you recognize that you
are
already 100 whole you don't need
a one-night stand you don't need
somebody to cuddle you in bed at night
you don't need somebody to look at you
in the eyes and tell you oh you're so
worthy
to me that you you're so loving
to me and i love you so much that you
don't need to hear those things in order
to be whole
that's the difference
now some people are blueprinted for the
process
of finding someone to mate with and then
to bring in a pack of like two or three
kids into the world
that then those kids have their own
unique
journeys and explorations right so some
people are truly blueprinted for that
process
so many of you are
going through the process of figuring
out that
you're going through the lesson of oh
[ __ ] this consumeristic possession
didn't make me happy
boom beautiful lesson that you've
learned right or
what you can do is you can listen to
this message
and be like might it be that this piece
of life has already went through that
process
and they're communicating to me so that
i don't repeat the same mistake in the
same lesson
so that you can have this rare candy you
can level up
faster you can make the realization of
the emptiness
of the external pursuit faster
if you make the realization of the
emptiness of the external pursuit faster
by listening to the people
that have been there you will actualize
and realize way faster the nature of
reality and your own unique
gift that you're bringing to society
okay the next one is another classic one
which is that i'm going to get fulfilled
by substances like alcohol and cannabis
and psychedelics and theogens
where i'm going to get fulfilled by
going out to clubs and bars and concerts
or by traveling the world
you have to recognize the emptiness of
that so for example 10 years ago
there was a process for me also of
binging on
alcohol binging on cannabis binging on
the
substances and binging on going to the
the clubs and the bars
and binging on traveling and doing the
things that
you have to do in order for you to learn
the lesson that those things are empty
and so take this again are you drinking
a lot right now are you smoking a lot
right now
are you trying to be happy by going to
travel to a bunch of places around the
world are you
are you thinking that going to concerts
or raves
taking mdma ecstasy do you think that
those things are
bringing you happiness because if you
simply
shift your perception from
i'm going to go out to alcohol and clubs
and bars
and traveling the world and concerts to
bring me happiness and joy if you make
the shift in perception to
actually i am peace and happiness
and joy my truest nature is an infinite
indescribable oneness
my nature is already wholeness and i
don't need
alcohol or cannabis or entheogens or
concerts or raves or traveling in order
to feel whole
now what i can do is if i'm very excited
about
within my blueprint to go and study
greek philosophy i may go and travel to
athens
and i may go and immerse myself there
for three weeks just enjoying the
studying of greek philosophy
that's completely different from i'm
going to travel
to berlin and go
and take a bunch of substances bunch of
clubs
and realize the emptiness of it now that
again it might be in your blueprint to
go through that process and learn those
lessons
learn about the emptiness of all of
these things for example with entheogens
this is really important if you
can imbibe an entheogen like magic
mushrooms let's say
and if you can uncover what it is trying
to tell you
on the first go or the first two or
three goes
then retain that reflect
on that sort of decentralized infinite
oneness that these
magic mushrooms are trying to tell you
and then don't go through the process
of needing to continuously redose on it
over and over and over again because
you've gained an attachment to what they
show you
rather than recognizing that you are in
your own nature what they are showing
you
you are already the infinite oneness
they are just
removing the clouds to help you
recognize you're the sun
so then just retain yourself
energetically as the sun
money job security safety this is
another big one culture
subconscious programming telling you
that you need
money you need a job you need a nine to
five you need safety you need security
you need these things
when it's actually the opposite you
don't need any of those things the
opposite is most true
which is that whatever you're
blueprinted for
find that first and then you will have
abundance come to you so rather than
going and getting
locked up in the nine to five cycles
instead turn inward identify what you're
blueprinted for
first and then from there
what you'll notice is that whatever you
pursue
that everything else that you need will
follow in your wake
all of the in it follows a very karma
yoga process where you have no
interest in the fruits but they come to
you regardless so the money
or the success or some of the
possessions like technology that you
need to help you actualize your goals
will come
and follow you in your wake but you have
no attachment to them
you have no dependency on the fruits you
have no
interest in the fruits they just come to
you
and then you keep actualizing your goals
which are in service to
other people they're not in service to
yourself you have to flip that as
quickly as you can
that you're not here to try and extract
things but rather you're here to be in
service to that infinite oneness
awakening
validation need lack want desire
recognize that
you're not here to feel
lack and to feel that you need to be
validated
but rather that you're already coming
from a place of wholeness
and if you put in your north star
position of desire
if you put recognizing the kingdom of
god that is already within you or
recognizing infinite oneness or
actualizing your greatest gifts and
goals
what's going to happen is you'll
perpetually come
from that place instead of coming from a
place of oh i don't feel whole right now
so i need validation and i need
materialistic possessions and i need a
boyfriend or a girlfriend and i need
alcohol in clubs
and i need these things that are
completely
empty but that i'm here to learn the
lesson of
them being empty so try and shortcut
that process as much as you can
that's the direct path the direct path
is recognizing the emptiness of
externalities and worldly pleasures
as quickly as possible so that you can
just like in the parable of the
parable of the prodigal son that you can
turn inward
so recognize the emptiness of
all of the externalities of all the
worldly pleasures this
is the direct path is to recognize the
emptiness of the indirect path so that
you can turn
inward and then feel the god sun
infinite oneness radiance
that is your truest nature and then
perpetually be in service
shepherding the creation awakening
i hope that was helpful
i love you thank you and
recognize the emptiness of all of the
externalities
as quickly as you can
make incremental changes like if you
need to delete all of those
hookup culture apps on your phone or if
you need to spend less time at shopping
malls or if you need to
spend less time drinking alcohol and
going out to clubs then do those things
pick up eckhart tolle's power of now
pick up
rupert spire's transparency of things or
pick up nisargata
maharaja's i am that and adhyashanti's
end of your world if you pick up these
books and you spend more time reading
them if you spend more time turning
inward if you spend more time
investigating who am i truly
you will recognize that there is a well
of honey that's infinite that's located
right here
underneath of the rock that you're not
as tapped into
because you haven't you've atrophied the
muscle of recognizing how profound the
kingdom of god is of just
being aware or being conscious of that
infinite oneness that we
truly are
so do like the video subscribe to the
channel if you haven't yet comment below
with where you're at in this process
share the video with other people that
you feel like it would resonate with
that's all infinite love thank you